well you're a salesperson you you're
former sales got seven years on it so
you saw through it words you know when
it's good and bad
totally and even though you see the
sales pitch every time you probably
respect the people that are doing it
well yeah and the people who are missing
the basics like remembering your name
you're like I'm not even gonna give you
the time of day yeah yeah you know it's
20 to is every now and then I've gotten
phone calls from like some political
whatever trying to raise money and you
can tell the kids reading off a script
mm-hmm I go first of all I'm not I don't
believe in politics I'm not giving you
any money but can I just talk to I did
this for years
you sound like [ __ ] on the phone dude
I'm like you gotta kind of have you seen
boiler drawers and an uncie they
actually listen the kids like thank you
so much i hate their interfering with my
day well i mean to the idiots that are
like a boss buddy boy like you know
those real sales guys that like gil from
The Simpsons hilariously that one guy
did yeah but I mean sometimes it's just
there so I mean a lot of these people
just have no soul I mean to get into
sales I was I would got into it strictly
because I was with this girl who her dad
made tons of money in sales and I had no
idea what to do with my life and I'm
like I'm gonna rock what he sell or he
worked for one of the big printing cut
like Kinkos or Canon or one of those
things were like just every business
needed a hundred thousand printers so he
just write you know this is a weird how
some people have figured out how to make
like you know uh what's his name Mark
Cuban is such a genius because he did
all the network yeah networking these
computers yeah becomes a billionaire off
phthalic and we find something people
need yeah three clients a year if we get
three clients in here well good yeah I
like urinal cakes like who the hell ever
thought of that you know the nuts thing
is that if you lose one like I like a
good [ __ ] right there's one
there's one stall I go into the gym to
take a [ __ ] and it's the one where the
scent comes out and it smells so good
whatever yes a little a little but it's
like a nice smell so whoever invented
those things yeah shooters never think
about that like what's next like yeah
why can't I do it I'm always wrong what
do you think people need hey I just I
never I'm never correct a bowling ball
case with a TV attached to it is just
one awful I never have good ideas have
you ever seen the movie boiler room
yeah years ago that's I mean because
Giovanni Ribisi sees character does the
exact same thing the guy calls up trying
to sound like the New York Times and
he's like no that's not how you sound
yeah that whole sell me a pen thing you
know yeah it's just oh you wanted funny
about the first sales job I quit I went
in I found out I was friends with
someone that I sold the payroll service
to they don't opened a business and I
had it on this report you had to fill in
this is the part that I hated where you
were what time you were there how long
you were there did they you know come to
the next sales part process or whatever
and my boss called and checked in on me
like later on he goes just wanted me was
there a guy from payroll company they're
trying to sell you and my friends like
yeah Mike like I know you know all right
just checking one to make sure he calls
me he goes there your boss is checking
on you Simon and I quit and the guy is
like Mike we're going to the top and I'm
bringing you with me we have visions
where we see you higher up in the invit
and I'm like I'm done I don't want to
I'm gonna bring in the other manager the
other manager comes in he goes Mike we
see visions for you I feel the same and
I go Todd just said that he goes all
right well hey it was good knowing you
so ridiculous dude yeah by the way
I've got something special you start
your pen pitch I like I like when Jon
Bernthal in wolf of Wall Street does did
sell me a pen thing it's the only time
I've ever seen it done successfully they
go tell me this penny goes okay can I
see your pen and they hand him his penny
goes right down your name and like I
can't he's like alright five dollars I
said this pen do you believe in
superstition okay yes pen your
grandmother's didn't get cancer
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]